I'm gonna try not to cry but you did
you're my life I'm the worst Packer of
all time we'll Welch luckily I have GQ
creative director Jim Moore here the
most expert Packer I've ever seen in my
life Jim please show me on stuff think
we all get really concerned about how to
pack that suit yeah can I tell you what
I've tried to learn yes jacket comes off
the hanger inside out one shoulder seam
into the other shoulder seam yeah I've
already lost you and I feel like that
means because I don't know how to do you
can actually pack your suits on the
hangers that you have at home then I'm
gonna go to my dry cleaners which I you
don't do it very often because the dry
cleaners will give you probably a whole
stack of these for no money
you go to your dry cleaner you say hey
can I have a roll of those plastic bags
exactly and I'm just gonna lay it in the
bed of the right side and fold it over
is the plastic from the dry cleaners
helping me permit wrinkles exactly okay
doesn't matter if that suit is five
thousand dollars or five hundred dollars
it's not gonna get ruined because of the
plastic bag because the fact that this
is a very indestructible hard case that
jacket those pants are not going to get
ruined so basically you're folding it
this way and the hanger goes down that
way I don't know what to say it's that
easy
if you have any style questions that you
want GQ to answer you want me who knows
Little Mix and nothing ask Jim and those
basically everything leave them in the
comment section and we'll see if we can
get it done
you